in the summer of 2007 in the heart of a
forest in northern california hundreds
of people were gathered for a yearly art
and music festival it was meant to be a
celebration a weekend filled with
creative expression dancing and sure
probably some illegal substances but it
was all said to be a mostly wholesome
affair and one that attendees had been
looking forward to all year on the
evening of the festival's first night
after a day of painting performance art
interpretive dance and folk pop fusion
the organizers put together a massive
bonfire everyone gathered around
roasting marshmallows and vegan hot dogs
and breaking out their acoustic guitars
for a sing-along it was all going well
and they were heading into the third
refrain of kumbaya when a group of
friends adding logs to the fire noticed
something odd some of the flames at the
edge of the fire pit were moving in a
different direction than the rest while
most of the flames flickered upward some
tilting slightly with the direction of
the wind these flames were moving
sideways against the wind stretching
themselves out towards the grass it
seemed bizarre impossible and they
wondered if first if perhaps the
brownies they had eaten earlier had more
than just chocolate in them but then the
flames kept moving taking on a familiar
shape they were dancing orange and
yellow flames there was no doubt about
that but they also seemed almost like
fingers the fingers extended outward
grasping for something attached to the
fingers was a hand then an arm another
hand joined it twisting into the grass
which dried and crackled at its touch
one of the friends a young woman named
flower attempted to alert one of the
event staff but they were too busy
trying to get their marshmallow to the
perfect shade of golden brown unable to
get any help she watched helplessly as
the fiery hands dragged a head a torso
and the rest of a humanoid body behind
them it looked like the shape of an
ordinary man with the glaring exception
that it was made entirely out of fire it
stepped out of the fire pit and began to
take slow halting strides toward the
gathered crowd now everyone took notice
of what was happening first they froze
in shock staring at this being of pure
flame unbearable heat rating off of him
as he moved closer and closer when he
reached out a hand toward flower and the
arm of flower's dress ignited in flames
on contact the first scream broke
through the silence when they marketed
this year's event as burning man in the
woods this was not what they had in mind
but there he was just the same a man
made of flames tearing through what was
meant to be a peaceful and happy event
with no dangers beyond exhaustion
dehydration and maybe a noise complaint
or two instead the crowd scattered in
every possible direction running for
their lives it was already too late for
poor flower who fell to the ground
shrieking in agony as the fire engulfed
the organic material of her dress and
the flaming man pulled her into its
deadly arms her screams went quiet
drowned out by the crackling roar of the
fire as it fed on her flammable body
once flower was nothing but a pile of
bones and ashes the entity began to walk
slowly purposefully through the woods
with its arms outstretched it brushed
its fingertips over everything it passed
every tree every stump every plant or
scrap of fabric torn off of a branch the
fire began to spread like well wildfire
by the time the first festival-goers
made it out of the forest and into the
nearby town to get help dozens of acres
of forest were ablaze and over 50 people
were dead the fire department was
deployed to the forest where they were
able to contain the blaze after hours of
work meanwhile word of the man made a
fire that destroyed the art and music
festival reached the only people
qualified to deal with such a creature
the scp foundation they deployed
operatives embedded in the local police
force who joined the fire department
under the guise of providing
reinforcements once the blaze was
contained and the area was largely safe
to enter they followed the path of the
fire and tracked the being responsible
for all of the destruction they found it
shrunk to the size of a small child
huddled in the fire pit where it all
began as if it was hiding from the fire
hoses then they apprehended the being
later designated scp-457
scp-457 is comprised of unknown
materials though obviously it is made up
of something flammable whatever it is it
is made up of something invisible and
impossible to detect by any known
scientific means the only visible aspect
of the entity is the flames it produces
which tend to make up a humanoid shape
as long as it has enough fuel to reach
that size if it does not have enough
fuel it shrinks in size becoming as
small as the single flame atop a lit
match in its smallest form it is
indistinguishable from any other small
flame except for the occasional display
of independence such as jumping to other
fires or flammable materials which you
can then use to grow larger when it is
large enough to take on a human form
scp-457 displays human-like intelligence
and is capable of communication through
writing which it does by burning letters
into surfaces with its flames or even
through speech though it lacks the
anatomy to produce a traditional voice
it produces coherent sounds via
pressurized superheated air as well as
the crackle of its flames if provided
with enough fuel to grow beyond humanoid
size the entity can split into two or
more beings depending on how much fuel
it is given however this split state
does not last as the separate instances
of scp-452 will attempt to attack each
other until they are the only one left
standing
scp-457 seems to want nothing more than
to consume more and more fuel and spread
as far as it can it has shown a
troubling ability to learn and adapt
purposefully breaking and interfering
with sprinkler systems in the building
and setting up elaborate traps for
personnel it does not like dr smythe
head of the research team assigned to
scp-457 conducted an interview with the
subject on a rare day where it was
feeling cooperative in order to better
assess its psychology and motivations dr
smythe entered scp-457's containment
chamber carrying a fire extinguisher in
case of any hostility on the part of the
entity he stood on the other side of the
blast shielded window for extra
protection it crackled pleasantly in the
corner seeming to welcome him inside he
asked if it was capable of or willing to
speak it answered yes he asked how it
felt about being confined it responded
plainly dislike no fuel no air when dr
smythe reminded the entity that it had
enough air and fuel to survive it argued
that it could not burn and had no fuel
to clarify dr smythe asked are you
saying that you cannot grow at this
question
scp-457 moved back and forth through the
small section of the room as if pacing
and looking for something it said grow
need must grow and when asked how it
felt it simply said hungry
as the questioning continued the entity
approached the window and stretched a
hand made a flame toward the glass for a
moment it stopped responding to dr
smythe in order to get the being's
attention back he casually brought up
the subject of water at the very mention
of it
scp-457 let out a high-pitched scream
and pressed itself against the window in
a threatening gesture dr smythe warned
it that it must move away from the
window or it would be doused in water it
moved back but screamed and hissed for
several more minutes offended and upset
scp-457 resumed its pacing at a more
aggressive speed and intensity all the
while it repeated want fuel want air
won't burn won't burn want to burn again
and again getting louder and louder as
it moved dr smythe was perplexed by this
behavior noting that there was no way
out and wondering what it could be
trying to accomplish at this point the
interview took a turn for the disastrous
somehow
scp-457 was able to damage the sprinkler
system and a section of the fuel
injector that had been providing it with
a small stream of fuel with the nozzle
broken open several gallons of gasoline
came flooding out allowing the entity to
grow to an incredible size and a sudden
massive destructive blast exploiting a
weakness in the blast shielding as
cp-457 was able to escape its
containment for several minutes burning
its way down the hall of the facility
until the larger sprinkler system
activated sending it hissing back to its
cell there it was apprehended by a team
of guards and herded into a new higher
security cell it is unknown how exactly
the entity became aware of the
weaknesses in its containment chamber
but this incident revealed that it is a
highly intelligent being capable of
problem solving however it learned this
information and figured out how to
exploit it the foundation realized that
more extensive measures would need to be
taken to keep it locked down and keep
the general population safe due to the
dangerous nature of scp-457's corporeal
form highly specialized containment
procedures have been put in place to
keep the flame from spreading the entity
is kept in a 5x5 meter chamber with at
least 9 inches of fireproofing in place
including asbestos and perlite the
observation window is blastproof and
resistant to extremely high temperatures
the room's opening is made up of
temperature controlled and airtight
chambers that can be sealed in the event
of an escape attempt the room itself is
kept at a high humidity level and a
drain has been installed on the floor
with a sprinkler system in the ceiling
and emergency hoses that can be operated
if additional water is needed a small
portion of the room is free from water
but only enough so that scp-457 can
maintain its shape and protect itself
from moisture any personnel that enters
scp-457s containment unit must wear
class a temperature controlled and flame
resistant suits and must enter in groups
of three two of the three members of
each group must be armed with blast
shields and fire extinguishers personnel
are not permitted to enter the
containment chamber for any reason other
than providing daily fuel or fixing any
issues with the room or its sprinkler
system in some ways its containment
procedures are reminiscent of a
particularly spicy variant of
scp-173 if the entity attempts to attack
any personnel it can be deterred via the
application of fire extinguishers or
hoses until it backs down if it escapes
from containment further sprinkler
systems will be activated throughout the
facility in order to contain the fire
the highest priority aside from keeping
the entity contained is keeping it fed
because it needs constant fuel in order
to survive the foundation is currently
prioritizing finding an infinitely
renewable source of fuel though many
have been proposed including the use of
other scps such as
scp-2689 and scp-124
no source has been officially approved
yet in the meantime they keep the
burning being fed and happy or as happy
as it can be it will never be truly
satisfied until a day arrives where it
can be permitted to spread as far and
wide as it wishes to burn and feed and
engulf everything in sight let's hope
that day never comes but if you start to
feel unusually hot if the walls seem to
suddenly blacken around you and you hear
the final crackles before the hissing
tongues of flame look at your bubbling
skin well by that point it'll already be
too late now go check out this scp does
not exist
scp-3930 the pattern screamer and
scp-173 origin story how 173 got to site
19 for more strange and unusual scps